the One Piece manga just confirmed that
Shanks is on Albert getting ready to
fight used as kit and taking his
roadponently this is a major reveal that
has incredible implications about
shanks's true power his real goal and
how the elbaf arc will play out once the
straw hats inevitably get there after
escaping from ecken island starting with
the imminent battle between the red hair
Pirates and the kid pirate does kids
stand any chance at all against Chang's
and what does this fight mean for the
end game of One Piece
author of One Piece has created two
groups for the final Saga that are
competing for the one piece treasure and
interestingly enough Luffy is part of
both on the one hand you have the for
yonko the most powerful pirates in the
world Luffy Shanks Blackbeard and buggy
but technically mihawk and on the other
hand the top fighters of the worst
generation which are again Luffy kids
and love which means that we now have a
total of six pirate Crews trying to get
their hands on all four Road Pony glyphs
and reaching love tail first and Oda now
puts two of the yonko up against two of
the worst generation law has been
attacked by Blackbeard while kit has
actively sought out Shanks Blackbeard
and Shanks want to get their hands on
kaido's road ponerglyph while law would
get the one that aokiji stole from
hulkig islands and kid is trying to get
the one that is most likely hidden on
elbaf protected by Jaguar dissolve the
man with the burning marks who has most
likely rescued it from O'Hara together
with all the rest of its ancient
Treasures this might actually be the
road Pony glyph that went missing from
fisherman Island where Shang saw it when
he was still part of Roger's crew now we
can of course not forget that both kid
and law have fought against kaido and
died both of them together have defeated
big mom however it would take a small
miracle for either of them to actually
win a one versus one against another
yonko so shortly after leaving juano
especially since both Shanks and
Blackbeard have been heavily
foreshadowed as two of the main
opponents that Luffy still has to face
at some point in the story but then
again who knows what sort of curveballs
Oda has planned for this final Saga also
when you think about it following this
exact pattern it opens up the
possibility that Luffy will run into
buggy crocodile and mihawks soon as well
however I do think it's fair to say that
Luffy has his hands full right now
there's an admiral and one of the
gurusai themselves coming for him with
an armada of 100 Marine warships and we
actually do not know yet if mihawk and
crocodile actually wants to compete for
the one
the first place so for now let's focus
on the battle between kid and Shanks now
when you put both of these characters
next to each other like this you will
notice that they share a lot of physical
similarities both have red hair both
have a scar over the left eye and both
are missing an arm and that last one is
especially ironic because kid lost that
arm in his first encounter with the red
hat Pirates it does turn out however
that it wasn't Shanks who cut it off in
fact kit never even got to see Shanks
during the fight in the first place
instead it seems like Ben Beckman was
the one who actually took his arm which
kind of makes it look like some sort of
really morbid joke on his ends I mean
maybe Beckman saw a kid and how similar
he looked to Shanks and then thought to
himself you know what would be hilarious
I do think that we're all about to find
out why the red hair Pirates are all
considered monsters and not just the
group of chill partying men that we have
seen so far in the story but for the
longest time it really seemed like was
the only yonko with only a small crew
and no territory this has been
completely busted by Oda at this point
because we have learned that Shanks has
actually his own part of the new world
that he rules over and his kid arrives
at elbaf we also get confirmation that
Shanks has a giant army of other pirate
Crews fighting for him just like
Whitebeard big mom or kaido what is
maybe the craziest part about this fight
though is that it's now 100 confirmed
that Shanks wants to reach laughtail
himself yes he did say that he wanted to
enter the race when he appeared during
wano however there was still a chance
that he simply meant actively helping
Luffy to become Pirate's King but in
that case Shanks wouldn't need kaido's
Road Pony glyph after all Luffy already
has that one which does mean that he
wants it for himself and this makes his
true motivations even more mysterious
than they already were after all he
could have just taken that pony glyph
from Luffy when he came to wano actually
Luffy would have probably just given
it's to him instead he just apparently
came to save Luffy and Co from greenball
very strange so let's put kid aside here
for a second and talk about what it
means that Shanks is in the bar here on
elbav with Dory and bragi and first of
all given that most theories that any of
us make don't end up coming true it does
feel nice being right for a change
because I've been speculating about
Shanks being the secret protector of
Alba for almost four years now in case
you wonder what the hints were for this
here's a very quick overview hellbath
which is really just the word fables
belt backwards by the way is the country
of giants which has a giant tree in the
middle of it as well and while Juana was
inspired by Samurai and Japanese
mythology elbaf is clearly based on
Vikings and Nordic mythology it's a
reference to the world tree yikrazil and
the Seven Realms one of which is the
Realms of the Giants and its ruler is
literally called Loki Alpha has an
island was first mentioned all the way
back in chapter 115 when the straw hats
first ran into Dorian bragi the two
Giant Warrior captains that are wish
tanks in the bar here already back then
both of them were wearing biking armor
and the ship of their giant pirate crew
was also a classic Viking ship and you
might not notice but one major
inspiration for One Piece was actually
the anime Vicky the Viking which was
produced in both Germany and Japan
funnily enough and you might or might
not have noticed that Shang himself
actually has a really strong Viking
theme going on as well that connects him
heavily to al-bath pretty much from
chapter one of the story but wait before
we get into more detail about all of
this in case you haven't noticed it is
almost March and in Japan that means
just one thing that's right Sakura's
season is around the corner and now you
might be wondering how you can
experience Japanese Sakura season at
home without going all the way to Japan
and boy do I have the solution for you
this is boxu the sponsor of today's
video it's a monthly Japanese snack box
filled to the brim with the most
delicious snacks and tea pairings made
by Family businesses here in Japan and
this box called Sakura and Kyoto were
actually just went the other week will
bring the taste of Japanese spraying
right into your living room or wherever
you like to eat delicious stuff like
matcha cookies organic rice tea or this
incredible looking Sakura cake that I'm
gonna have right now
um that was so good if you don't know
the drill yet you can use my code
ohara15 for 15 off your very first own
box of Japanese snack box and now back
to the video first of all shanks's ship
is exactly the same Viking design as the
ships from Elba not only that but Shanks
himself is also inspired by the Nordic
god tier now tyr might not be as famous
as Thor Odin or Loki but he's actually
one of the most powerful and important
gods in Nordic mythology he was
apparently the god concerned with the
formalities of War especially treaties
and also appropriately of Justice which
of course fits perfectly with shanks's
role throughout the entire story so far
stopping the ward Marine for it and all
on top of all that though tier is most
famous for sacrificing his arm to the
giant monster fenrir so that the other
gods could bind him which is of course
pretty much in your face considering
that Shanks also literally sacrifices
his arm to a giant monster in the very
first chapter of One Piece now one thing
that is still still unclear though even
after chapter 1076 is whether Shanks is
just an ally and guardian of elbaf or if
elbaf is actually under his Rule and
part of shanks's territory one argument
against Changs being the ruler of elbaf
is the existence of Prince Loki and that
big mom was confident that she could get
the Warriors of elbaf known as the
strongest army in the world on her side
by marrying of Lola to Loki so if Shanks
actually was the ruler of elbaf that
shouldn't have been possible in the
first place on the other hand though one
woman says in this chapter two Shanks
that they should be paying protection
money to him for keeping them safe all
the time kind of implying that Shanks
has control over the islands kind of
like with the Yakuza in Japan paying
protection money and Dorian bragi also
not only refer to Shanks as Big Brother
which in Japanese also sounds like the
respectful yakuzalingo but they also
willingly follow Shanks into battle even
though they are both captains which of
course leaves one very important
question on the table if Shanks is
allied with the Giants of elbaf right
now in whatever way how will USA be able
to lead them all at the end of the story
because that is something that has been
majorly foreshadowed ever since little
garden so let's look at what Shanks
being on elbeth actually means for the
elbeth arc and the straw hats going
forward and first of all to get it out
of the way if it wasn't already obvious
enough that Luffy and Co will be going
to elbaf soon Shanks being there is the
ultimate proof that it will happen just
think of all the story arcs that are
leading to this island there is the atom
tree that produces the indestructible
wood that the Thousand Sunny is made out
of it is also most likely the main
entrance to the sky islands and burka
which would make it the perfect Arc to
reintroduce or Rouge the one Supernova
that we have seen no trace of so far of
course we have also just learned that
the entire knowledge of the library of
Ohara has been transported safely to
elbaf2 by Saul making every Union with
Robin a must then there is this color
spread of the straw hats as Vikings and
let's be real if Oda had planned to skip
going to albaf altogether he surely
would have shown it off to us in all of
its Glory instead of shrouding it in so
much mystery and barely giving us a
glimpse of its Shoreline so far but the
two most important character arcs
culminating in elbaf that I want to see
of course are Luffy and USA especially
now that the red hair Pirates are
confirmed to be there you have of course
Luffy's overdue meeting with shangs to
prove himself as a great pirate but
before we get into that I want to first
talk about Usopp because I'm convinced
that al-bath will be his art as you
might know usop has gained the respect
of various Albert Giants throughout the
story including Dorian Prague oimul Kasi
and hydrogen in fact usab was inspired
by the Giants of al-bath to become a
brave Warrior of the sea and as usop's
lies keep coming true throughout the
story usup could really become the
leader of the Giants and Lead an army of
8 000 men strong into battle besides
Luffy like he once said also remember
that we have the mysterious Prince Loki
in Nordic mythology Loki is of course
known as a trickster and a liar but so
is USO both of them might actually be
quite similar in terms of personality
but while Uso values bravery and wants
to be like the Giants Loki most likely
values himself and oppresses the other
Giants and so Usopp could show his
bravery by challenging Loki to a duel
and now we suddenly have the classic
theme of David with his giant slingshot
versus the Giant Goliath and at this
point it would also be a waste if Oda
didn't give usop a malnir-like hammer to
parallel Thor and Loki as well and who
knows maybe another lie will come true
and usop might awaken his conquerors
haki after Luffy and Zorro something
that fans have been speculating for a
while now and on top of all that we have
of course also the entire relationship
with his father yasop the sniper of
shanks's crew in a way he is the one
responsible for Uso being a coward and a
liar in the first place because when he
left his son and his mother he left usop
with two choices resent his father for
leaving or as he did in the end
glorifying him after all why would he
leave his only kid behind if he wasn't a
Legendary Pirate with very important
work to do and this really hits home
when you realize that it's probably
exactly this insecurity about being left
behind that led to usop's Chronic lying
when we first meet him he lies about
being a great and powerful man having
had Many Adventures just like his father
because he feels like he could never
truly be this person in reality usop
sees himself as weak insecure and
worthless so finally confronting his
father and finding closure could truly
be the Breakthrough for usob that makes
him one of the most badass straw hats if
he isn't already but the biggest thing
about elbaf will of course be Luffy
finally meeting Shanks getting the
chance to prove himself to his mentor
and here it will of course be really
interesting to see what shanks's true
intentions are is he good neutral or
maybe even the secret villain of the
entire story so to find out what will
most likely happen when Luffy arrives on
elveaf to meet Shanks you can watch this
video right here with all the evidence
in the story so far thanks for watching